last speaker of the session michael kim
that's that's my talk
you
[Music]
hdmi
all right good
i guess i'm preventing you from going to
lunch so try to be efficient
so uh great i wanted to tell you a
little bit about some of the work i've
been doing over the past few years
trying to understand this idea of
fairness in algorithms and in learning
systems
[Music]
so um
these days algorithms are everywhere we
look i don't need to tell you that but
more and more um
algorithms aren't just computers for us
they aren't just uh calculators they're
really implicated in making
consequential decisions about people
so
you know for instance they're used in
medical risk prediction they're driving
cars they're running targeted
advertising campaigns
um and i think i like all of these
examples in that
in each of these contexts historically
the human decision makers that might be
involved in making medical risk
prediction or driving cars
have been highly regulated if you want
to be a doctor or drive a car you got to
get a license in this country
advertising is highly regulated by
federal law protects against
discrimination
on the basis of race and gender so as we
move towards uh systems where algorithms
are replacing human decision makers
becomes increasingly important to be
able to understand how we're supposed to
regulate these things
and what it even means for a an
algorithmic decision maker to be fair or
unfair
so perhaps you've seen examples like
this but we'll go through it where um
so
last year twitter users discovered that
if you upload
uh the pictures on the right here uh to
twitter
then uh in fact
the the cropping algorithm decides to
show you two pictures of mitch mcconnell
and omits the fact that barack obama is
in either of the pictures
and so users uh
tested this out across a bunch of
different
images and really found that
consistently the cropping algorithm was
putting forth white faces over black
faces
um and indicted twitter for uh bias in
this algorithm and so to their credit
twitter has taken some steps to try to
address the issue and has started uh a
a cool new algorithmic bias bounty
challenge
where uh they're gonna be
auditing these algorithms
um but
uh
the the thing about this is that uh the
the approach to fairness here is very
reactive the only thing that uh will
be able to sort of address in a bounty
program like this
are
unfairnesses or biases that are already
out there and really it would have been
great if we could have anticipated these
types of biases up front and done
something about it so that's sort of the
approach that we want to take is a more
foundational approach
where we're going to try to observe and
anticipate patterns of algorithmic bias
and really formalize these patterns into
definitions in the language of
theoretical computer science math and
statistics
and really uh
the goal is to balance the need for
general purpose solutions and uh
understanding the context in which these
algorithms are going to be deployed
and the hope is that the definitions
that we come up with uh really will help
us to clarify what we can and cannot
expect from machine learning predictors
and sort of the eventual goal the hope
is that we can develop efficient machine
learning solutions
that come with a provable certificate of
certain fairness properties much in the
way that your modern browser provides
you with a certificate of security based
on cryptography
good so to give uh sort of a flavor of
the types of definitions that we're
working with uh the main thing that i've
been thinking about for the past few
years is called multi-calibration
and so multi-calibration is a condition
on predictions that says that predictors
should be calibrated
not just overall but even when you
restrict yourself
restrict your attention to
sub-populations
um where these sub-populations are
defined by a computational class so we
formalize the protections and the
strength of the guarantee
through
the lens of complexity theory and
thinking about uh sort of interpolating
between uh
group notions and sort of the
information theoretic ideals
so
indeed multi-calibration strengthens the
protections of group fairness
and we show how to
actually learn these things we reduce
the problem of learning multi-calibrated
predictors to more standard machine
learning tasks
good so i'll actually i want to talk in
a bit more detail about some newer work
some recent work that we're trying
to
generalize multi-calibration and extend
it a bit further
and so this work is with
dwark rheingold brothelum and yonah and
we're calling it outcome
indistinguishability
where we're putting forth a new goal for
learning and the the the perspective is
that perhaps uh rather than working in
the pac model we want to learn a
probabilistic model that in some sense
is indistinguishable from the ideal
outcome model or the true outcome model
which we'll call nature
so i think it's best illustrated by this
cartoon
where we can think of it as a game of
sorts where uh
i will
give you
a labeled sample so an individual x and
an outcome y
and the the outcome will either be drawn
from nature from the true model
or from
uh the model that i'm developing the
computer program that i'm developing
and i'm going to send this across and
not tell you which one i sent you
and then the distinguishers task will be
to guess whether the whether the sample
whether the outcome came from nature
or our model of nature and the goal will
be to develop a model
for which the distinguisher can't win
this game better than random guessing
so a bit more formally we we think of
nature as a joint distribution over
individual outcome paris
as is standard in supervised learning
and
the observation is that for our model
distribution for any predictor that we
have a real valued predictor that's
predicting a probability we can think of
that as actually giving us a generative
model
so specifically we'll sample an
individual still from the marginal
distribution on nature
but then we'll resample their outcome
y y tilde according to the predicted
value according to the bernoulli
distribution with p tilde of x and so
then the condition is uh an
indistinguishability condition between
x y star and x1 tilde
good so whenever we talk about
indistinguishability then you have to
ask indistinguishable to whom and
if we allowed ourselves all powerful
statistical distinguishers then it's not
hard to see that it would require us to
learn nature exactly which is impossible
from a small sample
and so what we focus on instead is a
computational relaxation where we fix a
class of efficient distinguisher
algorithms a
and then we say that a model is a
outcome indistinguishable if this model
distribution that we were talking about
is indistinguishable from the true
distribution
according to all of the tests defined by
the distinguisher algorithms
good and so
how does this connect to before
it turns out our main result here is
that outcome indistinguishable outcome
indistinguishability actually captures
multi-calibration in a very strong way
there there's tight connections we can
go back and forth between the two but
actually this framework is even more
general and so it really sets up a
cool idea that perhaps we can
think of fairness properties as some
sort of indistinguishability conditions
so uh
an idea that we're working on
formalizing is that perhaps a fair
predictor should be thought of as
indistinguishable from a certain ideal
predictor
good so finally i just want to conclude
that these ideas of outcome and
distinguishability and multi-calibration
have seen applications beyond fairness
so we have a number of works thinking
about them in terms of learning to rank
and robust estimation and a number of
other people have
done some cool work related to outlier
detection
and agnostic learnability i think uh
really the main contribution of the oi
framework so far is setting up the
framework
and hopefully
you can apply it to your favorite
learning problem too uh thanks so much
happy to take questions
[Applause]
okay so does the distinguisher know the
star and if so how does it have access
to it right so so that's a great
question the
the in our model the distinguishers have
access to d-star through samples but
don't say no the exact formulation
because
oh yeah that's a great question so so uh
we didn't think about it in terms of
gowns but uh it's very natural to think
about
the the distinguisher game is quite
similar to the discriminator game that
people like to think doesn't convince
we're thinking about a supervised
learning setting
whereas gams typically think about
unsupervised but it's very related
let's thank all the speakers
you might use the receptions